Stannis Baratheon: What are you reading?
Shireen Baratheon: The Dance of Dragons.
Stannis: What’s it about?
Shireen: It’s the story of the fight between
Rhaenyra Targaryen and her half-brother Aegon
for control of the Seven Kingdoms. Both of them
thought they belonged on the Iron Throne. When
people started declaring for one of them or the
other, their fight divided the kingdoms in two.
Brothers fought brothers, dragons fought dragons.
By the time it was over, thousands were dead.
And it was a disaster for the Targaryens as
well. They never truly recovered.
Stannis: The Dance of Dragons.
Why is that a dance?
Shireen: It’s just what they call it.
Stannis: Hmm. Doesn’t make much sense.
Shireen: I think it’s poetic.
Stannis: If you’d had to choose
between Rhaenyra and Aegon,
who would you have chosen?
Shireen: I wouldn’t have chosen either.
It’s all the choosing
sides that made everything so horrible.
Stannis: Sometimes a person has to choose.